I'm going to show you the craziest skill
shot that any Esports player has ever
hit all right so ti8 it's pain gaming
versus Team secret and we've got a
midlane grudge match between weha and
mid one so we's absolutely styling on
him he almost solo kills him here but
the defining blast leaves him at just
like one HP the thing is invoker has a
very special ability so for those who
don't know invoker's Sun strike is a
global pointand click nuke what invokers
will often do is they will try to aim
the sun strike at people while they're
watch walking back from their Tower so
as mid one's walking back to his base we
has already looking for a timing to hit
this sunstrike we has staring at the fog
of War he can't see any of this so he's
going purely off of intuition as to
where mid one might be and that's when
it
happens throw it
out what he threw that totally blind
I've seen some crazy Suns sprc and donut
that is the craziest one I've ever seen
theing weha invoker